watching another person cry is an
uncomfortable and intense experience
even when that person is only on a
screen when done well crime scenes can
pack a powerful and emotional punch but
there are plenty of crime scenes that
are just plain awkward to sit through
from unintentionally hilarious - just
plain cringe-worthy here are some of the
worst very sad spoilers ahead the room
in the climax of Tommy Wiseau's cult
classic the room
Johnny has just lost everything his
fiancee has left him his best friend
hates him and his life has proven to be
just a shallow Mirage in his rage and
grief he destroys the apartment he once
shared with Lisa the love of his life
the problem is that as anybody who has
seen this so bad it's good film can
attest why Zoe's acting prowess
resembles that of an alien asked to
replicate human behavior after watching
two episodes of Days of Our Lives did
not hurt her it's not true it's both did
not hit her oh hi mark
as Johnny fails about in a cyclone of
destruction his bizarre guttural wailing
takes the awkwardness of this scene to
the next level it almost sounds like
he's crying
but the discerning eye would be
hard-pressed to find any real tears on
why Zoe's face the scene is horrific
surreal and hard to watch but then again
so is the rest of the room vampires kiss
nobody does over-the-top quite like
Nicolas Cage from his bonkers
performance in Bad Lieutenant port of
call New Orleans - the magnum opus that
is the Wicker Man he sets a high bar for
the overdramatic
but those movies don't hold a candle to
how over-the-top cage gets in vampires
kiss the film is full of classic bits
but if there's a single moment that
embodies the awkward glory of cages
performance it's when he cries his
character has just tried to offer
himself but the gun he was using was
loaded with place in his anguish he
whimpers quietly before erupting into
bombastic hoots cages filmography is
filled with classic amped-up emotional
breakdowns like this but vampire's kiss
is definitely one of the most memorable
Harry Potter and the Goblet of Fire
Daniel Radcliffe has turned in many
memorable performances starring in the
Harry Potter series expertly nailing
moments of comedy tragedy and the trials
of adolescence but when you play the
same character for as long as he has
you're bound to have a few moments that
fall flat at the end of Harry Potter and
the Goblet of Fire
Harry has just witnessed the return of
the evil Voldemort as well as the death
of his friend Cedric Diggory teleporting
from this nightmare back into the at the
conclusion of the Triwizard Tournament
the contrast between Harry's grief and
the jubilant oblivious crowd is chilling
it doesn't help when Jeff role-playing
Cedric's father sweeps in and over acts
as well with two actors uncomfortably
sobbing over a corpse the scene shifts
her poignant to just plain awkward scene
like this isn't supposed to be fun to
watch but it's also probably not
supposed to be this uncomfortable Moulin
Rouge it's a safe bet that director Baz
Luhrmann never learned the meaning of
subtlety well this is often led to some
of the most sweeping beautiful and
unforgettable scenes in film history
other times not so much
[Applause]
this duality is best exemplified in
Moulin Rouge where audiences are left
squirming through some comedic Lee over
the top crying from Ewan McGregor in the
film's climax MacGregor's character
Christian is caressing the body of his
love Satine who has just died in his
arms Christiane begins with some soft
whimper
but soon revs up to an almost musical
person though considering that the film
is a musical this isn't entirely
inappropriate while Lerman includes many
scenes in Moulin Rouge that were
actually supposed to be funny this crime
scene is probably the funniest moment in
the entire film sines the most
vulnerable scene at M night Shyamalan
signs is carried out by four very
talented and capable actors
unfortunately with a family eating what
they believe will be their last meal
before an alien invasion we get a prime
example of there being too much talent
in one room stop crying
everyone in this scene is a wonderful
actor but with all the weeping and Mel
Gibson aggressively stabbing on his food
the scene goes past poignant and into
hilarious it's hard not to laugh as an
all-american family breaks down over
french toast and spaghetti rocky 3 the
rocky franchise is a national treasure
and Sylvester Stallone brings the iconic
eponymous boxer to life with an
emotional fragility that has endeared
him to audiences that emotion is front
and center when rocky has to say goodbye
to his dying trainer a heavyweight boxer
sobbing crocodile tears down a
smashed-up face is obviously not going
to be pretty but man is it tough to
watch
[Music]
the scene is heartbreaking but
Stallone's overacting takes it from
tragedy to unintentional comedy we may
love rocky for how in touch he is with
his emotions but Stallone may have done
his job a bit too well this time the
spider-man trilogy there are few
cinematic whalers better or worse
depending on your perspective than Tobey
Maguire in Sam Raimi's spider-man
trilogy Maguire cries so much as Peter
Parker but it was tough to narrow things
down to just one scene when he's not
fighting crime you're bound to find him
scrunching his face up into a tiny ball
of despair that said Peter Parker is a
great character precisely because of how
human he is there's honestly a lot to
love about how strange Maguire looks
when he cries because let's be real we
all look awful when we cry real tears
are ugly as uncomfortable as it may be
to watch requires waterworks and the
spider-man movies are about as real as
they get mean worthy facial expressions
and all thanks for watching click the
looper icon to subscribe to our YouTube
channel plus check out all this cool
stuff we know you'll love to
[Music]